Before we go further, I'd like for us to have a quick blueprint overview so that we can make sure that everyone understands a few of the blueprint concepts we're going to be making heavy use of inside of our example.
Now the first one is understanding blueprint flow. Now this is a term that's used to describe how the blueprint graph goes from left to right just like you read in English.
So no matter what we're doing, we're always going to be starting at the left hand side, so we'll start here, and then we will go to the right, process our output, and then we will be able to choose something here at the end.
But it's very important to understand this because this is going to happen a lot inside of our projects.
Now there are some nodes that we will be looking at using as well as some additional nodes here that I just want to call out.
But first off is the node I want to talk about here is the branch, and the branch allows us to do things on a true or a false, and this is Unreal's if-then node.
So if something is true, we're going to do this. If something is false, we're going to do this.
Notice the condition here. This allows us to tie this to a variable so we can have a bunch of different variables, one that looks for something like, you know, the player has the key, and if they do, then we will open the door.
If not, we will give them a message that says, you know, you don't have the key.
There's a lot of things that we can do with this one simple branch node in terms of flow controller, how our project is going to progress from one area to another.
Next, we have a flip-flop. So the flip-flop allows us to have something input here, and then what's going to happen is it's going to go A and then B, and it's going to repeat this behavior for the entire way the project is running.
So I like these because we can put these on a button, and if we click the button, it's going to do something like turn on the light.
And then if we click it again, it will turn off the light without us having to develop a really complicated trigger to, you know, is it been turned on?
Yes. Then we reset something. This is just really, did we turn it on? Toggle A. Did we toggle again? Then toggle B.
After that, we have a sequence. Now, a sequence allows us to execute a sequence of events based off of an input.
If we want, we can use this add pin here to add more than inputs or I should say than outputs and fire off as many things as we want.
Next to that, we have a switch on int. This allows us to add again additional outputs here.
But instead of just firing them off in succession, this like the sequence node,
this allows us to enter an integer here that will execute that particular output that we have.
So if we put a zero, it's going to do default.
If we were to add a pin here and do one, it will do the next one to the next one and so on and so on.
Last but not least, we have gate and multi gate. Now, we won't be making use of these nodes in this project.
It's just something I wanted to call out because these do allow us to do some very complex flow control.
Gates allow us to do actually execution based conditional checks so we can check for
have things been entered into or states and things of that nature using these.
And again, while we don't necessarily utilize them in this particular tutorial, it is good to know about them.
Now, this slide deals with time control because flow control is again how our project is going to deal with data.
Time control is how our project is going to be dealing with times in turn of things like maybe a countdown
for a level or maybe you're keeping time to do a time trial or some other nature.
But time control is very important.
And the first thing that we can do to control the time with our delays.
Now, there is a delay, a delay and delay until next tick and a retriggerable delay.
Now, while delays are great when you're prototyping, the problem with any of these delays is that once you have started the delay,
there is no way to stop it or restart it or go around it.
A delay, if you say, let me put a delay in the five seconds, there is no way to stop that delay from happening.
You have to wait for the full five seconds so you can't say interrupt it.
Now, if you want something that you could interrupt or something that's just a lot easier to keep time with,
there are actual two nodes called set timer by event and set timer by function name.
But we're actually going to be utilizing these in our code here to create a timer for our example in a little bit.
But these timer nodes are really cool because you can set multiple timers for whatever you need.
And then anywhere through Blueprint, you can actually call the timer and stop it or start it.
So they're extremely useful.
The last thing that I want to talk about is a timeline.
So a timeline allows us to animate between two values.
So let's say we wanted to go between zero and one.
We can use a timeline to animate that going from zero to one.
The last thing that I want to talk about here is with a delay, just a little pro tip.
If you set the duration down here to zero, that's actually going to give you a one frame delay.
And that's actually one of the best use cases for a delay is if you were trying to act as a single frame delay,
you can set it to point zero and it will act as a single frame delay.
And this is great if you need to slow spawning down or delay something just by a single frame until something else happens.
This can be a really great way to do that inside of Blueprints.